de
tamamladık artık
Herkese merhaba Öncelikle iyi akşamlar
Günaydın güzel şeyler içine beni davet
ettiğiniz için teşekkür ederim
Evet Ecem'i de söylediği gibi ben de
ortaklarından Öğretmen Lisesi o zaman
Öğretmen Lisesi öğretmen lisesinden
mezunum ve bir zamanlar sizin
Oturduğunuz koltuklar da tarafta ben de
vardım liseye başladığım süreçten şu
anki Almanya hayatıma kadar geçen süreyi
de
edindiğim deneyimleri sizinle Nar
sizlerle paylaşmak istedim
şuan bir çok neden bir sunucudan sonra
konuştuğum için bu büyük bir dezavantaj
oldu sanırım Muhtemelen çok
gelemeyeceğim Kusura bakmayın şimdiden
lisedeki hayatımdan bahsedecek olursak
Aslında çok başarı Az önce değildim
derslerde ve keçilerde hep uyurdum
Çünkü Yatılı okulda biraz böyle uyuma
problemi olabiliyordu benim için eşi
zaman öyle parmakla gösterilen ve
geleceği parlak bir öğrenci olarak
görünmedim ve dördüncü sınıfa geldiğimde
edemez üniversite sınavına girmek için
hazırlanırken Herkes harıl harıl
çalışırken Ben kafamda direkt mezunu
kalmayı kabul etmiştir özellikle
çalışıyordum hemen bir sonraki sınav
için
çalışıyordum ve olanda oldu ben dördüncü
sınıftan sonra çoğu arkadaşım
üniversiteye gittiğimde bende Pırtımı
toplayıp ailemin yanına dönüp tekrar
sınava hazırlanmak için döndüm
ama bu mezuniyet yılı mezunu kaldığım
yıl dışarıdan negatif bir şey gibi
gözükse de benim hayatımdaki dönüm
noktalarından birisi oldu aydınlandım
bir zaman dilimi oldu Çünkü şöyle
bu
yatılıda zaten yatılı okumanın birçok
avantajı hasta dezavantajı da olabiliyor
lise yılları 18/14 yaş aralığına denk
geliyor ve bu yaş aralığındaki çocuk
gibi düşünmekten daha yetişkin gibi
düşünmeye evlendiğiniz bir dönem ve dış
etkenlerden çok kolay etkilene
biliyorsunuz çok kolay Çevrenizde
popüler olan şeylerle katıla
biliyorsunuz Bu benim bu çok normal Bu
arada yani birçok insan bunu yaşıyor ve
ben de bunu yaşadım ben liseye girdiğim
zamanda mezun olduğum zamana kadar benim
Abi sen de şu an nasıl bilmiyorum ama o
zamanlar Bizim listemizde
de sağlık alanı çok popülerdi herkes
Doktor olmak istiyorum Diş Hekimi
fizyoterapistlik müthiş bir patlama
yaşamıştı Herkes bağlamlarda bir bölümü
kazanmak ve bu işleri yapmaya yapmayı
hedefliyordu Ben de öyleydim ben de işte
kaza Ama sen tıp
ve ateşte sağlık alanında bir alan
olarak döndüm liseden ailemin yanına ama
mezun olduğum yıl benim kuzenim Bu arada
Ortaklar anadolu öğretmen lisesinden
Beyazım o da benim yüzüme kaldığımız o
da tıpa başladım ve biz onunla
Buluştuğumuzda Bunu unutma kitabını
göstermişti Ben onun kitabını gördüğümde
O benim için bir aydınlanma oldu bir
kafamda böyle bir çakralar açıldı ve
gerçekten ilk düşündüğü ve aklımda
beliren düşünce şuydu ben bunu
istemiyorum yani ben gerçekten bunu
yapmak için benim istediğim şey bu değil
Bunu fark ettim Daha sonra kendini
sorgulamaya başladım Bence bu bir
insanın hayatında en önemli şeylerden
birisi Çünkü insan Bence kendini
tanıdığı sürece hayatında mutlu olabilir
Bunu sosyal hayatınız içinde söylüyorum
kariyer hayatınız içinde söylüyorum ama
hiç kimse sizin hakkınızdaki düşünceleri
sizin hissettiklerinizi sizden daha iyi
bilemez en yakınlarımız bile bu aileniz
olur arkadaşlarımız öğretmenler veya
herhangi bir rap sizi sizden daha iyi
kimse tanıyamaz ve kendimizi tanımamız
için de sorgulamanız gerekiyor Ben
neleri yapmaktan zevk alıyorum neleri
yaparken sıkılıyorum bunun gibi soruları
sormaya başladım bundan sonra ve
bu sorgulama sürece hiçbir zaman da
bitmiyor Hayatımızın her evresinde
Farklı durumlar oluyor farklı sorunlar
oluyor ve sizde yaşıyorsunuz Hepsinden
önce daha önceki yaptığımız analizler
artık değişen size uyumaya biliyor o
yüzden bence bu gerçekten güzel bir
özellik
liseyi Oo mezunu kaldım yılda neler
sorguladım Berkan Sizin için de nacizane
bir fikir olabilir Mesela ben sayısalcı
olduğum halde Ben dedim zaten Ama bu
sözel çalışmayı kesinlikle sevmiyordum
yani sözel dersleri çalışmak benim için
bir küfret olmuyordu şuan burada Mustafa
hocam da var ve ondan özür diliyorum
biyolojiden Kimyadan bu da biraz daha
sözleri Çelik sayısal derslerden hiç
zevk almıyordum Neyi seviyordum
matematik Çalışmayı seviyorum
geometrik a motive ederek çalışması
yapıldı bunları sevdiğimi fark ettim
Onun dışında sordum yani çok soru vardı
ama işte bu birkaç örnek vereceğim size
bir tanesi ben bireysel çalışmayı daha
çok seviyorum gruplar çalışmakta
çalışırsak o kadar bıraktım olduğumu
düşünmüyordum onun gibi sorular sordum
sordum ve Bu soruların cevapları benim
mühendisliği etti Ben aslında sağlık
alma değil Mühendislik istiyormuş Bunu
fark ettim ve o yolun sonu geldiğinde
sınava girdim sınavdan sonra puanları
açıklandı Ben kafamda kendi içimde
mühendisi Ben yüklemiştim Ama tabii ki
de bu Muhtemelen herkesin yaşadığı gibi
çevremdeki Herkesin bir düşüncesi bir
planı vardı benim üzerimde ailemin
öğretmenlerimiz Ve tabii ki de bunların
hiçbirinin Art niyetin olduğunu
düşünüyor Herkes tamamen ile niyetiyle
size yol göstermeye sizin daha iyi
yerlere gelmeniz için tavsiyelerde
bulunuyorlar ve maalesef Türkiye'de
Pelin anında bahsettiği gibi bayan
olarak özel sektörde çalışmanın
zorlukları var Bunlar yani
görmezden gel Gelecek noktalar değil ve
bu gerçekten siz de motive edebilir
bulmanızı zorlaştırabilir bir en büyük
kaygısı buydu Benim ailemin Özel
sektörde etmemi çalışabilir misin
yapabilir misin Ama ben o o zaman da
kesinlikle düşüncenin arkasında durdum
düşüncemiz savundum Ya ben kendimi
tanımıştım ve Ne istediğimi karar
vermiştim
ve bunu gerçekten mantıklı argümanlarla
ve sizin de bunu istediğinizi karşı
tarafa geçirdiğiniz zaman onlar da ikna
oldular ve ben Mühendislik tercihleri
yaptım daha spesifik Peki nasıl
bilgisayar mühendisliğine karar verdim
diye sorarsanız açıkçası orası Çok
bilinçli değildi biraz
şansın yardımıyla iyi bir bölüm tercih
etmişim Mühendislik istediğimi
biliyordum ama hangi mühendisliği
istediğimi tam olarak bilmiyordum müzik
dinlemeyi çok seviyorum
müzik dinleyerek çalışırım ve böyle
fiziksel aktivite içermeyen bir
mühendislik alanı istiyorum Böyle İnşaat
alanlarını vesaire gitmeyeyim Oturduğum
yerden çalışırım diye bilgisayar
mühendisine gittim
ve benim Böylece üniversite hayatı
başlamış oldu Üniversite hayatın
sürecinde Ama kendimce üniversiteye
Başladığım zaman doğru olduğuna
inandığım ama mezun olduktan sonra ve
çalışmaya başladıktan sonra dönüp arkaya
bakın aslında yanlış düşüncelerim olduğu
beni kenetli dini düşündüğüm bazı
kalıplar var Bunlardan ve sizin
yaşınızda ki çevremdeki kişilerle
konuştuğum da
aldığım sorulan bazı defalarca sonra
aynı sorular var Onlar üzerinden devam
etmek istiyorum sohbete
Öncelikle Mesela en çok sorulan
sorulardan Birisi şu şu de benim daha
önce bilgisayar ya da yazılımla ilgili
bir geçmişim Yok hiç ilgilenmediğim
Bilgisayar Mühendisliği yapabilir miyim
Tabi ki de yapabilirsiniz benim de yoktu
Yani normal bir bilgisayar
kullanıcısından daha fazla bir yazı
yazılmaz ilgili bir fikrim yoktu Ben de
gör kullanıyordum YouTube kullanıyordum
Google arama yapıyordum bu kadar ya bu
üniversiteye girdiğimde de tanıştım Evet
ilgilenirseniz Bu sizin için avantaj
olur ve ve avantajlı bir şekilde
başlarsınız ama ilgilenmiyor sanız Bu
bir dezavantaj değil Bence sadece nötr
olursunuz sıfırdan başlarsınız Ben de
öyleydim sıfırdan başladım şunu da
söylemek istiyorum yazılım alanında
çalışmak istiyorsanız gerçekten çok
sabır gerektiren bir meslek ve sürekli
değişen dinamik bir alan teknoloji her
gün de şu an herhangi bir yerde yeni bir
teknoloji
anons edilmiş ve muhtemel üç ay sonra
ben kullanacağım olabilir bu kadar hızlı
değişen bir alan ve sizin sürekli
öğrenmeniz gerekiyor Sürekli takip
etmeniz gerekiyor o yüzden
biraz sabırlı olmak gerekiyor öğrenene
kadar Bazı şeylerin oturana kadar bir
bu bahsedeceğim şeyde
de yazılım çok böyle biraz daha Analitik
düşünme yeteneğinizin olması gereken bir
meslek daha çok şimdi çok soğuk bir şey
hiçbir şey göremiyorsunuz Yani elle
tutulur bir şey yok bir sonuç
alıyorsunuz Bir input var Bira tut var
anasını aradaki proses tamamen soyut ve
sizin onu yönettiği yönetmeniz gerekiyor
bu analitik düşünce yeteneği nizde
zamanda geliştiriyorsunuz burada sabır
devreye giriyor
o yüzden yazılım bilmeden başlamak Bence
bir dezavantaj değil yani belli bir süre
o alışma sürecini atlattıktan sonra ben
dediğim gibi ama önce Kendinizi
tanıyorsanız bu alanda başarılı
olacağımıza inanıyorsanız Bence
başarısız olmak için bir de başarılı
oldu başarısız olmak için hiçbir neden
yok başarısı doğru söyledin n sesinden
anladığım zaman
bu ve diğer bir şey benim de üzerinde
çok düşündüm acaba Hani böyle mi oldu
şöyle olsa dedim iyi bir üniversite
olsun işte iyi bir üniversite mezunu
olamazsam ya da ile İyi bir üniversiteye
giremezsem ya Bu yazılım alanında
yapamaz mıyım vesaire Tabii ki de bu
söylediklerim sadece yazılım alanı ile
ilgili diğer Mühendislik alanlarında
diğer mesleklerde kulvarlar çok farklı
kriterler çok farklı olabilir
Pardon ama yazılım alanında dünyanın en
iyi üniversitesi ne gitme gittiniz
Mesela bu sizin en iyi dünyanın en iyi
yapımcılarından birisi olacağınız
anlamına gelmez Çünkü e üniversite şöyle
işliyor yazılım zaten kendi içinde çok
fazla alt dalları olan bir meslek çok
fazla alan var Ve bunu alan yazıp dört
yıl boyunca bu alanlardan biraz biraz
ama ben size göstermeye çalışıyorlar
hepsini görmek zaten mümkün değil sadece
en popüler olanları en temel olanları ve
siz Hoca dersi gelir Sadece teorik bir
başlangıç yapan Gerisi tamamen size
kalmıştır o yüzden
üniversiteden Ziya üniversite sizi çok
iyi bir yazılımcı yapmaz Siz Kendi
kendinize iyi bir yazılmış olursunuz
tabii ki de o ilk başlangıç o
başlangıçta verilen teorik bilginin de
bir kıymeti var en azından nereden
başlayacağımızı görürsünüz ama soğanı
tamamen size kalmış bir şeydir
Burada da zaten Mesleğiniz boyunca da
kullanacağımız bir öğrenme metodumuz
olmalı dediğim gibi sürekli değişen ve
sürekli öğreneceğimiz bir sürece girmiş
oluyorsunuz ve
kendinize ait bir öğrenme metodu
geliştiriyorsunuz geliştirme yani
bulursunuz onu bir şekilde herkesin
farklıdır bu metodu ama entem Az önceki
yani
kişiden kişiye değişmeyen şey interneti
doğru kullanabilmek bilgiye ulaşan
ulaşmanın yollarını doğru bilmek
interneti Google doğru kullandığımız
sürece doğru kullanabildiğiniz süreli
istediğiniz kaliteli birileri
ulaşabilirsiniz ve kendinizi inanılmaz
geliştirebilirsiniz ve üniversitemizdeki
hocamızın ya da üniversitenizin çok
kaliteli olup olmaması orada artık devre
dışı kalıyor O services bir başlamak bir
basamak atlatmıştır ondan sonrası Siz de
zaten bu her alanı farklı alanlardan
dersleriniz olacak dediğinizde hiçbir
alanda böyle uzmanlaşmış olarak mezun
olmuyorsunuz Sadece genel bir bilginiz
oluyor işte bazı alanlarda ve öyle mezun
olmuş oluyorsunuz o
detaylandırılmış uzmanlaşma
üniversiteden Öyle beklentiniz olmasın
o iş hayatında olan bir şey demek bu
ama bunu da güzelliği siz orada farklı
farklı alanları gördüğünüz için
hangisini daha çok severek hangi dersi
daha çok severek yaptığınız görüyorsunuz
ve hangi yazılımın altalanın alanı size
daha uygun olduğunu ellerde kariyerinizi
ona göre nasıl şekillendirebiliriz
elinizi karar verebiliyorsunuz öyle bir
güzelliği olabiliyor
bu onun hiç başka diğer bir konuda not
ortalaması Bence not ortalama İyi bir
not ortalamasıyla mezun olunursa
işte iyi bir yerlerde iş bulunabilir Bu
da kesinlikle benim gözümde yanlış bir
düşünce bana göre not ortalaması önemli
ama işte not ortalaması olunca iyi bir
iş sahibi olma kısmı yanlış benim için
not ortalaması Sadece size bazı
alanlarda basamak olarak kullanıp daha
güzel kapılar açabilir ilk öncelikle
şunu söylemek istiyorum
öğrencilik
öğrenci kimliğinizi sonuna kadar
kullanır Çünkü öğrenciyken bazı şeyler
daha kolay önünüze açılabiliyor belki
bireysel Ben şimdi sapı olarak gidip
yapamayacağım şeyleri size öğrenci
kimliğinizle çok daha kolay
ulaşabilirsiniz mesela bunlardan birine
Erasmus Erasmus'a gelmeden önce
kesinlikle
yapmanız gereken şeylerden birisi Hani
burada ben yapım yapmadım ya da doğru
bilip yanlış bildiğim şeyleri de
anlatıyorum bir isteme üniversiteden
mezun olana kadar bir yurt dışına çıkın
yani bu üç günlük tatil olur bir
haftalık tatil olur ya da bir proje olur
vesaire bunları yapın inanın çok
değiştirecek sizin hayata bakış açınızı
çok değiştirecek sizin
Sizin güveninizi kendinize olan
güveninizi artıracak Bu gerçekten bu
hayatımızda gönderecek O benim yaşadığım
aydınlanma lardan birini yaşatabilir onu
söyledim zamanda aldım geri bildirimler
oluyor olumsuz anlamda işte euro dolar
çok pahalandı bize problemi var ya da
işte gidenler mutlaka bir tanıdığı
vardır vesaire öyle gidiyorlar Bence
bunları da Hiç aldırış etmeyin Çünkü ben
bunların üçüne de sahip değildim çünkü
ben Çiftçi bir ailenin çocuğuyum Almanya
geldiğimde hiç tanıdığım yoktu vesaire
Ama dediğim gibi o öğrencilik kimliğini
kullandım Ve ve İlla yurtdışına gidin
dediğimde Avrupa'ya Amerika'ya
uzakdoğu'ya gitmenize gerek yok Bize Siz
kabul eden ülkeler var mesela ya da
kurları Türkiye'ye yakın ülkeler var
Oralara gidin bunu söylemem de kalmaç
dilini kültürünü
bilmediğiniz kurallarını bilmediğiniz
bir ortamda
hayatta kalabildiği nizi hayatımızı
idame ettirdiği nizi bu etmeniz Bu
gerçekten insana çok büyük bir özgüven
veriyor ve insan yapısı anatomi
istediğim hormonal ne derseniz varlık
olarak biz gerçekten her şeyi
yapabilecek
güçteyiz gerçekten her şeyi yapabiliriz
çünkü o
psikolojide bahsedilen kampusu bozon
rahat ortamınız yetim rahat ortamımız
dan çıktın çıktığımız anda vücut sizi
ayakta tutmaya çalışıyor ve ister
istemez pratik ve karnınız ön plana
geliyor ve sorunlara çözümler
buluyorsunuz ama Okan Kurt uygulamamıza
zaten sizi
tetikleyen şeyler olmadığı için pratik
zekanızı Belki o kadar da aktif
kullanılmaya biliyorsunuz O yüzden
zorluklarla karşılaştığımız da bence be
ya da istediğiniz şeyler olmadığında
Çünkü hayat inişli çıkışlı olmadığında
bu ve bu perspektiften baktığımızda
daha kendinizi güvenli ve
yapabileceğinizi inanmış olduğumuzu
göreceğinizi düşünüyorum çünkü
zorluklarda olduğunuz zaman orada bir
çözülmesi gereken bir sorun vardır ve
onları çözmek için uğraşırsınız ve
Çözümü zd-11e bul atmışsınız Dur bir
başarı elde etmişsiniz demektir O yüzden
bence yurtdışına çıkmayı
o fikir yani o deneyimi yaşamadan
üniversiteden mezun olmayın dediğim gibi
not ortalaması burada yurt dışına çıkmak
için size yardımcı olabilir Erasmus'a
gitmek için Erasmus staj yapmak için
vesaire
Yani belki değiştirmiştir Şimdi burada
ben 3 yıl falan oldu mezun oldu ama hala
değerli diye düşünüyorum ama sizin çok
iyi bir not ortalamanız var diye daha
yüksek çok daha fazla Maaşlar ya da Cup
UV Vay bir işe alım süreci maalesef
Türkiye'de de
size bir fayda kazandıracağını
düşünüyorum Çünkü benim üniversiteden
sonlarda mezun olan arkadaşım da ilk
5'te mezun arkadaşım da seni sonunda
aynı şirkete gidip çalışmaya
başlamışlardı Muhtemelen de çok yakın
Maaşlar alıyorlardı
[Müzik]
Onun dışında size söyleyebileceğim neler
var
bir de ben Almanya'ya geldiğimde Ben
Erasmus stajı alma Yeni geldim daha
sonra kaldım staj attım şirketten iş
teklif alıp kalmıştım ve bu süreçte
artık sosyalleşir arkadaş edinmeye
başladım bir farklı bir ortamda hayat
kurmaya başladığı bir dönemde o zaman
gerçekten çok
üzüldüm kendim adına bir nokta vardı
insanlarla Muhabbet etmeye başladığımda
Bu yukarı herkesin çoğu insanın bir
hobisi vardı işte
bir ya bir enstrüman çalıyorlar ya bir
düzenli spor yapıyorlar ya işte resim
Vestel ve sanat aktiviteleri ile
ilgileniyorlar ama benim böyle bir hobim
yoktu o zamanlar ve tamamen böyle ders
çalışmak vs projeleri yapacağız staj up
vesaire Bunlar odaklı yaşamışım ama
geriye dönüp baktığımda Aslında
hayatın sadece bundan ibaret olmadığını
mı görseli Şimdi daha iyi olurmuş o
içindeyken farkedilmiyor okul
hayatınızda sürekli bir savaşım
mücadelenin içinde Siz mücadele
ettiğiniz Şehit dersleriniz vesaire
oluyor belki de işte bazen aileler ya da
işte çevreden etkileniyorsunuz işte
derslerimizin iyi olması için ve diğer
şeylere farklı bu sosyal aktiviteler
öncelik verilmeye biliyor Ya aslında
Bence bunlar da insanları bir insan çok
geliştiren bir şey Bir de de şarj eden
bir şey farklı insanlarla tanımı
tanışmamızı sağlayan farklı bakış açısı
pazarlara bilecek sosyal aktiviteler de
var ve bunlar da sizin hayatımızı
yönlendiren şeyler olmalı
İşte o yüzden böyle tanışmaya
başladığınızda insanlarla Biraz muhabbet
ettikten sonra onlar hobilerinden
bahsetmeye başlıyorlardı ve ben orada
tıkanıyorum
kesinlikle bir hobiniz olsun sevdiğiniz
bir şeyi düzenli yapın ve gerçekten iyi
gelecektir size
[Müzik]
ya benim sanırım genel olarak
söyleyeceğim şeyler bunlar
dıb nacizane kendi Yaşadıklarımdan size
tavsiyeler vermeye çalıştım dediğim gibi
kendinizi tanımayı öğrenir sorgulama
hiçbir zaman
bırakmayın düşüncelerinizi duygularınıza
kulak verin ve kendinize güvenin Her
şeyden önce g şu an her şeyi yapabilecek
güçte özellikle zaten bizim sistemimizi
gayet çektim
dersler kariyer anlamında zaten çok
başarılı ama benim okuduğum zamanlarda
olsun mezun lardan da gördüm tanıştığım
insanlar olsun genel olarak hayat görüşü
olarak da kaliteli insanlar o konuda bir
sıkıntı yok Sadece ben kendimde de
yaşadığım şu anki Kendinden küçük derde
gördüğüm bir güvensizlik problemi var
ama siz kendinize güvenmezseniz zaten
kimse size güvenmez O yüzden o
özgüvenimizi korumakta
koruyun Kendinizi hep inanın
böyle yani biraz sohbet tadında oldu çok
profesyonel konuşmadım Kusura bakmayın
ama zaten çok da beceremiyorum Umarım
nacizane tavsiye ederim Size biraz olsun
İyi Fikir vermiştir bir kişi bile
bu birazcık olsun değiştirebilir semme
Mutlu baba baba baba
[Müzik]